[Music]
while imperfect measurement is a crucial
part of marketing on mobile there are
plenty of valuable metrics available in
mobile and throughout this lesson I
cover key metrics for various mobile
marketing activities whether you are
examining an SMS program a search
campaign or an app see which metrics you
should track and how to spot mobile
specific problem spots make sure your
mobile program is successful by
identifying valuable KPIs and using them
intelligently in this section you will
learn to express the importance of
measurement on mobile even with
imperfect technologies to correlate key
metrics to track for a given mobile
marketing service and to explain the
inherent limitations of measurement on
mobile and it reminds me of that
familiar story about 50% of advertising
works we just don't know which 50% I'm
here to tell you and I hopefully have
made the case for you in a variety of
ways that we actually have more ways of
knowing if something is working for
instance in our Ford example if somebody
texted in off of a television spot or
off of a print ad we not only know that
we got impressions we know how many
people might have listened it in or
watched a spot we have the ability to
say this many people picked up their
phone and did something so that's good
but I also want to not sugarcoat this
there are some things that we can
measure in mobile and there are many
things that we need to get better at but
people who are way smarter than me say
that they can't afford to wait until
everything is locked down before they
get into this channel just because as we
mentioned many many times our consumers
our prospects have migrated there and
you can't one more cliche fish where the
fish were on you need to go where they
are now
all right so what can we track now I'll
throw out the word lot I think that
there are many things that we can take a
look at and say all right we created
this campaign what activity did we see
first one for messaging and email we can
look at how many messages were sent out
and we can look at open rates now how do
you do that you work with a vendor who
has a dashboard there are a lot of
different flavors and a lot of different
UI is when it comes to this but it's a
pretty simple fact - no messages that
were sent out and then you can take a
look at open rates you've been doing
that for years with email could do the
same thing with messaging for search you
could also look by keyword or by device
or by click to call so you are asking
people to do something and you can take
note one one example that I want to
throw out there is let's say you're a
brand and you're doing mobile marketing
and you want to use different channels
to to get your message out there one way
to do it is if you're using short codes
is to have a different keyword in one
channel versus another what I mean by
that is let's say you're running a
campaign and you have facebook you can
hat you can say text the word fly to
your shortcode and if you have a the
same campaign running in a different
marketing channel say email you can have
the word airplane as your keyword and
then when you see how folks are
responding to that you can talk about if
one channel is performing better than
the other you can make adjustments along
the way it's really a good example of an
a/b test you might want to include both
or you might want to say you know what
I'm really seeing more activity more
pick up on one versus another so that's
a good way to track also you can also
track impressions - conversions on
mobile web and apps we're getting better
better at that there are things like
deep links which allow us to know that
we're going from from to a specific
place within an app and and as we go
literally month by month
year by year the granularity allows us
to to get even more insights into our
campaigns
but there are also many hurdles and
inhibitors for us to measure I know that
this whole idea of cross channel
journeys and one of the biggest things
that people are presenting as solutions
are hey we can we can track the journey
of the consumer from one from the time
they get up in the morning until the
time they go to bed at night and that
that's really not the case some
companies are getting this closer than
others but some things that are holding
us back are things like lack of
standardization and I mentioned QR codes
in my Macy's example even today there's
a lack of standardization when it comes
to QR scanners through many people when
they purchase a phone or when they will
get a phone from their employer
there's no QR scanner that is on the
device out of the box so you have to
choose one maybe you're going to
download it from the App Store and there
are different scanners and different
standardization so not every QR campaign
runs the same way I look back at text
messaging was also in a lack of
standardization place where you couldn't
send messages across carrier several
years ago and one of the ways to
kickstart text messaging programs was
when standardization happened and also
the price of texting came down which is
with which coincided with that another
hurdle is this whole fat-finger concept
and unintended actions and I exercise
regularly I don't think I have
especially fat fingers but I have a
pretty small phone I'm not one of those
who's bought into the concept of having
the size of a tennis racket next to my
ear so I have a standard smartphone size
if there is such a thing and I'm still
hitting places my engaging with content
engaging engaging with advertising that
I wasn't intending to do I wonder if
there's something that the brand is or
the network is is trying to get
unintended clicks to get their action up
I hope that's not the case I
believe that people don't wake up in the
morning it's wanting to do bad things
but there is unintended actions that are
being caused by that fingers and I think
there's an imperfect tracking of ad
placements you would think that if you
were to run a campaign if you're a brand
or a business and you said I want to run
on these particular publishers through
this particular Network there would be
and if you asked five different people
to run that report you would get that
report the same way with the same
results we're not at that place yet and
so attribution is needs to get better
but I'll remind you as we close out this
section that there is enough that we can
measure and enough proof that the course
that we take is leading to our business
intended result be it drive traffic to a
storage drive traffic to a website
promote a new product that we can't wait
so I hope that helps
it's a it's really a critical area and
something that I would implore you to
lean on your vendors lean on your
agencies or those in your in your world
to ensure that there is as much tracking
and as much measurement as possible
here are the key takeaways
while measurement isn't perfect we can't
afford to wait until it is open rates is
one way to measure SMS and email
campaign results on search you can
measure by keyword device or click to
call the granularity of measurement is
improving months after month tracking
the customer journey is the Holy Grail
but not yet fully realized Hey once you
become an expert in digital marketing
then subscribe to the simple learn
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn up and get certified in
digital marketing click here